what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
man I was looking through the comments
for the first infinity video we did and
like people were screaming at me to
finish the rest of it people were just
like you gotta finish infinity man it is
it is an amazing story it is so good
like I understand where you guys are
coming from but yeah okay so in the
first video like we talked about how we
had two stories going on at the same
time you have the Avengers in space
because you have the builders who are
just like this really ancient race who
were responsible for basically the
creation of everything and we're just
like running across the cosmos just like
obliterating all these planets and stuff
and so the Avengers I basically want to
go check it out at the request of like
the members of the Galactic Council and
so on so basically you have like this
army composed of all these empires
across the universe which it all banded
together for the purpose of trying to
take on these builders and they all got
deuced on like they all got Rhett
they just weren't prepared and then like
you had Santos who invaded earth with
the black order and like they show up
and they crush everybody like almost
everybody look Honda is like the only
country that really succeeds in finding
anybody off because you know Black
Panthers are beasts so saw like picking
up with this this whole battle that goes
on with the with the Avengers and the
builders the Galactic Council and
everything like it's really just retreat
right like the first skirmish they
engaged in they were just crushed by the
builders and so what they ended up doing
was taking refuge on like a massive
citadel of sorts but the builders
started sending out all these sentient
drones they were just like destroying
this facility and it was a message right
it was a message going out to the
universe you can run you can hide but it
won't last long we will find you no
matter where you go and so what this did
is it put all these different races in a
position where they had to they had to
make a choice either they could bend
they could acquiesce and they could give
up to the builders or they could fight
to the death and die and like almost all
these empires you know every single one
of these races that had betted span for
thousands and thousands and millions of
years it was basically just giving up
the Centurions were the first ones to
fall the chameleons fell next and then
the creek now these are all races that
have appeared over the course of various
eras in in Marvel Comics now this also
still brings together the Galactic
Council of course you have Ron in the
accuser who speaks on behalf of the Kree
Empire and then you have people like
like gladiator of the Shiar and then
you've got Jason of Spartak the father
of Peter quill you've got all these
people who are just kind of banded
together and for the most part the
Avengers were never allowed into the
Galactic Council because everybody hates
Earth but this whole thing deals with
the idea of like Captain America
stepping in alongside Thor as an advisor
of sorts and really just like a handful
of the Avengers
everybody's speaking as part of this
Galactic Council but these are all the
various empires that exist all
throughout space so you've got the brood
you've got the Scrolls you've got the
Crete on Niles you have all these
different races that exist there and
they're all basically you know more or
less saying the same thing everyone
except Captain America the answer that's
being given by virtually everybody is no
victory can be found here the only role
option we have is to basically give up
the Captain America's response is but
why though like we can win all we have
to do is find a way to win this is kind
of ironic because Captain America is
talking to people who are part of our a
part of races and empires they were
mature races when humanity was fledgling
when Humanity was just now emerging onto
the scene and so what Captain America
says is that at this point we have to
find a way to bolster our forces and
when we face off against the builders
some of our number were captured if we
can rescue them and rescue those who
were not necessarily part of our teams
but having captured anyway we can
increase our number in that capacity and
it's a smart move liberate innocent
people liberate refugees liberate the
superheroes and all of them will rally
to our side and that's what happens
Captain America an eland Thor says we
need bait we need somebody to go in
there and we need someone to dupe the
the builders into focusing on us so they
don't look at what's going on over here
and that's exactly what happens Captain
America and the Galactic Council send
their ships in and they just operate as
bait they go in they fight against the
builders and the builders see this ask
why are they here again like are they
really wanting to fight again and that's
how it's designed to come across be a
distraction take their attention away
from what you're really trying to
achieve and what we end up finding out
is the builders made a mistake the
builders made a huge mistake
Navy it made a very very costly mistake
because once we get in there once some
of the forces of Captain America's
armies get in there then they start
liberating different Avengers one of the
Avengers they liberate is the Incredible
Hulk and let the Incredible Hulk breaks
out and just starts crushing everything
like literally destroys the ship on his
own just starts ripping through every
single device again fine from there like
they immediately teleport him out but
the cool thing is that they still have
to destroy these other two weapon ships
that are controlled by the builders so
they in turn send in Thor along with a
handful of other people and of course
they're able to pull it off by just
destroying things but what this does is
it brings in star brand now star brand
we talked about before right like it's
this idea that you have what's called
the wide event and the wide event was
basically an initiation that took place
that whenever there was like a massive
Universal threat really
once every generation a new person would
be chosen to be the star brand but it
was one of these things where they would
have however much power they needed for
a particular point in time it's really
kind of a caveat is one of those things
were just kind of sort of like here's a
character that lets me do whatever I
want to do at any particular point in
time but they're not omnipotent and
indestructible they can be destroyed but
star brand serves this purpose he
basically destroys a huge portion of the
Builder army which in turn like allows
some measure of the tide to turn but
again this is not the full brunt of the
Builder army this is just a portion of
it picking up with a tail and Thanos
shows back up to the inhuman City
because remember Black Bolt the king of
the Inhumans was told you've got 24
hours when when Corvus glaive showed up
at the home of the Inhumans he said
you've got 24 hours either you pay the
gauntlet or you pay the tribute the
gauntlet is Thanos comes here and raises
this city to the ground the tribute is
you kill all of your kids between 16 and
22 and bring us their heads as proof
Black Bull says no these days none I'm
not killing any of our kids only that he
basically evacuates the entire league
has the the whole city of Attilan
evacuated so that when they show up
there when Thanos shows up there there's
nothing left the only exception is
lockjaw and Maximus the mad the brother
of Black Bolt now Maximus the mad being
here serves a couple purposes the first
is that all of the Inhumans are going
through the teleportation device known
as Eldrick who was an inhuman at one
point I guess it was uh yeah I guess he
was and once he went to the mists he
basically became a door that's almost
like the siege perilous that when you go
through it it takes you wherever you
need to be at that particular point in
time but Maximus the mad and in lock jaw
the teleporting dog are really the only
ones left and Maximus basically
activates a massive bomb underneath
Attilan itself so when Thanos shows up
Danice arrives and says look man you
have 24 hours and you're 24 hours is up
now I'm famous man so like it's nothing
for me to destroy this place if I
obliterate the entirety of a talent for
you it's the end of times for me it's a
Tuesday so we can do whatever you want
to do let you doesn't matter to me man
tell me what you want what you want to
do do you want to die or you just want
to sacrifice your kids and blackbolt
just screams at phantoms now old-school
black bolt would have probably
obliterated the earth had he screamed
like this as loud as he possibly cut but
black bolts power has been toned down
over the years to make his character one
that can be defeated for the most part I
mean it depends on what you're talking
about for example like if you read house
of M he whispers at the villain
apocalypse destroys apocalypse and wipes
out what amounts to about a hundred
acres of land probably a little bit more
as if you have this like he screams and
not nearly as much destruction happens
so it really kind of depends on what
error you're talking about now how
certain Black Bolt was stupidly
overpowered like it was he was
criminally oaky it was insane but black
bolts screaming serves a couple of
purposes the first is to try to destroy
Thanos and the second is to activate the
Terrigen bomb to basically detonate this
terrigen bomb on earth now from here we
transition to a city called a rollin
which is basically hidden on earth now
this is very very important because
really up until this point there wasn't
really any such thing as like secondary
in human cities right like in Marvel
Comics you had a tiller and that was it
what Attilan did and how it functioned
was contextual for example Attila was
basically a hidden city on earth with
the Inhumans lived and it was that way
forever and ever and ever and then Paul
Jing is in jail II in 1998 wrote
Inhumans vol 2 they basically told this
12 issue story where Black Bolt tricked
his own people he literally orchestrated
an assault on a Talon so that his people
would it would finally agree with him
when he says we need to leave earth and
so Attilan took up residence on the blue
area of the moon that led into the
events of war of Kings when eventually
the inhale the Attilan took over the
entirety of the Kree Empire eventually
they came back they ended up you know
returning back to earth again
and then they just sort of reside above
the city of New York and they've been
there ever since
but there have never really been other
inhuman cities this is really the first
time that we start to see Marvel expand
this now Jonathan Hickman really did
this for the sake of this story and the
reason why is because were you ended up
having like the main city of Attilan
where the inhuman royal family has
always resided there were members of the
royal family who defected or even you
know even just like other members of the
in human society that basically broke
off but in this city of a role and what
you have is a shard of the Terrigen
crystals and what it does is it allows
this city to basically implement
terrigenesis among its own people but
only once every generation and so the
result is that they hope that people
won't gain like the best minds or
different abilities or what-have-you but
we pick up with a guy named Thane and
Thane is basically just a healer that's
really kind of like the quote/unquote
gift that he has but the indication here
is that he's never actually been exposed
to terrigenesis he's really more of just
like a medic but he's not one of those
people who's been chosen for
terrigenesis what is up happening is
that when this bomb goes off the
Terrigen mists spread throughout the
world now for those of you guys who are
wondering and Marvel Comics right now
and especially the events of like
Inhumans vs. x-men why the Inhumans had
risen upon
that's the way they did this is the
reason why this is the story that saw
the detonation of the Terrigen bomb and
the Terrigen mists spreading throughout
the west of the rest of the world and
what Marvel did was actually pretty cool
because what you had was a line of
stories that came immediately after this
written by Charles Soule so you had in
humanity you had in human that basically
explored like the aftermath of these
these Terrigen mists spreading
throughout the world and all these you
know basically hidden in humans that
didn't know they were in human subtly
going through the process of
terrigenesis out in the middle of
nowhere and subway stations walking
along the street and office buildings
and capitol buildings all throughout the
world leaders even became Inhumans not
realizing they were inhuman the entire
time the problem is that Marvel's
squandered that and instead going into
all-new all-different marvel they pushed
the x-men into the background they try
to promote the Inhumans which everybody
knows doesn't work because nobody really
cares about the Inhumans and so because
of this like with this bomb going off
Thanos is like okay man so like that's
your answer your answer is that you want
to fight then we can fight just be aware
man like when you fight me I fight to
the death I'm probably gonna kill you
because like you've irritated me and
that's just what's gonna happen so we
sort of like amelie he starts screaming
right he's like where's my son tell me
where my son is because he knows the
Inhumans know the location of his son
but he won't like blackball won't give
it up now of course at this point
pretence is at the window
Thanos had basically lied to the black
order saying well it's just it's a
tribute is what it is these are the
things I demand just do what I tell you
to and don't ask questions now Black
Bolt figure it out earlier on there the
whole subtext was that Thanos was
hunting for Sun and because Black Bolt
knows that and Thanos knows Black Bolt
knows that then we're just throwing all
pretense out the window and it's just
like okay you know that I'm here looking
for my son tell me where my son is and
if you don't tell me I'm going to
destroy you and I'm gonna destroy
everything you care about now what this
does is it leads in to one of the most
beastly moments in the history of comics
it's one it's like one of the greatest
Thanos moments of all time black ball
goes to scream if they don't just like
you know what dude enough man if this is
how it's gonna be
he's like fine then man but keep your
secrets carry them with you to the
crimes like smash his head in the ground
I'm just like dude Thanos how beasts are
you like knocks out Black Bolt in one
hit and he's like fine if this is how
it's gonna be the like I will find my
son myself and I'll kill him myself that
boys gonna die and with Fame having
undergone terrigenesis that his and
human genes are activated and suddenly
his powers begin to emerge although he
doesn't really have control over it now
at this point man this matters when the
story gets murders when the story just
so good for
if you are a fan of Thor now is your
time to shine because what happens if
Thor shows up right like when you have
the the builders who were on Crete and
like Captain America is like okay so
like basically we have to surrender like
we have to give up so they send a guy to
Tikrit right you know to the Crete world
Apollo and like the you know Romani
accusers is is like there is you know
Captain America and US forces they're
sending an emissary here to basically
surrender to give up to you guys and so
Thor shows up and Thor's talking to this
builder they're told look you can't be
arms and Thor's like whatever those is
hammer into the skies is lokay fine on
my own so the builders talking to them
Thor is like look I came here to discuss
terms of surrender and the Builder is
like no there are no turns there's you
give up and you take a knee or like I
kill you and then we destroy the rest of
your allies so like what's it gonna be
and so like it's crazy right because
like while this is happening like
everybody's praying like all the
accusers are there and like the Galactic
Council is watching this like all eyes
are on Thor so that was like taking me
and so Thor just niels bohr thor kneels
down he's like okay fine I surrender we
take a knee and so like it's funny
because the Builder starts talking trash
right he's like humanity's place is to
take a knee
like your place is below us we're
builders people don't want you here like
no one wants you here so we are going to
do the universe of favor and we're going
to eradicate you suddenly they hit like
there's there's this thing like you know
you're you're with like Captain America
those guys they're like they're like hey
gladiator like we have incoming and he's
like what is it in Captain America is
like it's a reckoning it's what it is
Thor's hammer comes flying back down BAM
it goes punch it right through this
building pushes a hole right through but
Captain America is like you gotta if
they can be broken they can be killed
that's it they're like we can destroy
these guys we can kill builders they're
not indestructible they're highly
durable but they're not indestructible
and so Thor's like alright huge stories
like grounding the accuser got a
question for you Ranas like what's up
he's like do you have free men and women
here and Ron is like yes it was like do
these freedom of free men and women will
they fight for what they believe in
Ron and says yes Thor rallies the entire
Kree are me to their son an army of
thousands and thousands of people
rallies them all and says it's time for
battle and Captain America's response
when the questions ask my gladiator like
what comes next Captain America's
responses now we went now we finally
take that the universe with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the Rob
corfu guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
FUS
[Music]
you